so the streaming has started I can see
it on YouTube and
other
yes
hi good evening folks uh we'll be
starting the learner Spotlight session
right on time uh meanwhile uh we are
just getting settled in and uh meanwhile
let's just introduce ourself to the
folks here so I'll just introduce myself
on the chat here so I'm rashak Khan and
I'm joining all the way from Bangalore
India and I'm thrilled to be your host
today and uh drop us a hello on chat
here and let us know where are you
tuning in from so let the conversations
begin and once again uh welcome to the
session we'll be starting right on time
in few
minutes
I can see introductions coming in from
folks who have joined us I can see folks
have joined from Bangalore Pune
kpur I can see Rob has joined from
Bangalore I can see Pine from Pune
here I can see someone has joined from
Michigan as well D good morning good
good morning at your end I can see John
has joined from Tamil Nadu I can see
Amit here is here from kpur so keep the
introductions coming and we'll be
starting the session uh just in few
minutes
awesome uh I can see a lot of
introductions coming in on chat and
folks are still joining in meanwhile
let's go to the ground rules quickly uh
so we have quick three easy ground gles
here you need to put on your questions
in the Q&A box if you have any questions
for our speaker here and and you can
just find it right beside the chat box
uh and the session has been recorded in
case you want to go through the
recording of the session again uh you
can expect a followup email with the
recording
click and uh this program is powered by
uh simply learn worlds number one online
boot camp uh we basically are very proud
that we have been in the Dig space for
almost 13 years and uh we have advanced
almost five lakh plus cers uh in 150
plus countries and we have 40 plus
global accreditions and 800 plus
qualified trainers and we are very proud
uh for that uh we have categories of AI
machine learning data science business
analytics cyber security cloud computing
devops and many more like that um so
before we start let's get to know each
other a little better and uh understand
basically what kind of experience are
you joining us from uh so there's a
quick pull on your screen which you can
see so we would love to know how many
years of experience do you currently
have so uh there are five quick options
here the first one currently studying
fresher uh second one zero to three two
years of experience third one uh 3 to
seven years of experience fourth one 8
to 12 years of experience the last one
more than Rel experience so please do
let us know uh how many years of
experience do you currently have before
we start the session let's get to know
folks who are joining us you know come
from uh different different set of
experiences usually and uh before we
start the session we would love to know
a little about you so as I was speaking
I can see the holes moving and so that's
great we've got a really active audience
here and I can still see the
introductions coming in on chat here so
that's great keep that coming in and uh
we already have our speakers here with
us uh Mr kab Dalal and prent TR and
we'll be starting the session in uh few
minutes after this experience
for I'll just give 10 seconds more for
for the poll
here okay I can see most of the folks
have already shared the responses for
the poll here so that's great uh for a
few of the folks who are still putting
down their experience on the quick poll
you see on your screen here so how many
years of experience do you currently
have please do let us know on the poll
here before we start the session and
once again welcome everyone to the
learner Spotlight
webinar
awesome I can see most of the folks have
already shared the responses on the poll
here so let me just quickly end the poll
in 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll and also share the results
with you so we can see that 36% of the
folks who have joined us are currently
ly studying and freshes and we can see
16% of the folks have 0 to three years
of experience 20% of the folks have 3 to
seven years of experience and 11% of the
folks have8 to 12 years of experience
and 16% of the folks have more than 12
years of experience so we have gotten
folks from different different uh
experiences here so that's good to know
thank you so much for sharing that with
us um moving
on uh I would like to uh invite uh Kash
Dal uh you know and introduce them to
you folks uh so uh with a rich
entrepreneur background spanning over 17
years he is the co-founder and Chief
Operating Officer at simply learn kup uh
is a graduate of IAT Bombay and IM am
lakau and has successfully scaled
businesses including his first Venture
in.com uh Kashi started his career in
uni LEL uh prior to venturing into the
world of startups uh but kab is more
than just a successful entrepreneur
Beyond his uh successful uh professional
achievement ments kashf is a certified
diver and ever reader of fiction and a
devoted Star Tech Enthusiast so please
join me and extending a warm welcome to
Mr Kash
dalag thanks RHA hi everyone it's great
to host you today and thanks thanks all
of you for joining in today I have the
pleasure to chat with prasan prasan
thanks for joining us prasan you know
let me start with the introduction so
pran is a mechanical engineer by
education he's a data analyst by
profession um he started his journey
with bpcl as an engineer and now is a
data visualization coach and the founder
of Tabo um pran is a you know he's he's
had an amazing journey where he's
transformed his career from starting
with a different uh you know job of
campus and then after that really having
a passion for the field of data and Ai
and then uh you know uh he's a person
who's gone through through a couple of
programs at simply learn in the field of
data and AI um so in his journey he
holds uh International titles from Tabo
such as Tabo Visionary and tblo
Ambassador and he's a proud simply
learner and has over eight years of
experience um where in the past he's
been associated with Brands like
American Express bat petroleum Mahindra
and Mahindra and currently he's on his
entrepreneur entrepreneurial Journey so
PR really excited to have you here and
thanks for joining in and sharing your
story with so many others who are
perhaps at a point where you once were
where you were trying to figure out that
you know how would you course your
journey so welcome to this call and
thanks thanks for taking time out thank
you so much kab thank you so much for
having me
here so let's let's get it rolling I
think uh to the audience you know we'll
we'll chat over the next 30 40 minutes
uh we'll we'll try to ask person a few
questions and understand his journey and
you know different things that helped
along the way um if you have any
questions please keep writing in I think
uh we'll keep looking at it if if a
question is relevant to what we are
talking about we'll take it along with
the flow uh otherwise we'll address all
questions at the end so please do share
your questions uh on the chat window U I
think one other aspect for the audience
so at the start when Russia did the poll
we we got a good idea that you know
we've got people across uh some of
students they are they are in college
trying to figure out about how to start
their career there are some with Fair
bit of experience 8 12 years of
experience um so I think what we'll try
to do in the discussion with person and
person would love to uh you know you
could also keep it in mind while you are
sharing your experiences that we've got
people across your entire Journey that
you you started at some point now you've
got seven eight years of experience and
uh you know gone through a lot of
different um experiences along the way I
think how do we make it helpful for uh
the entire audience for this call today
so that each each person can take away
something and and benefit from the call
so I think we will try to cover as much
as we can so maybe to get started PR I
think I'll I'll start with uh you know
uh one question just to kick it off that
you know you were a mechanical engineer
and you had started your career with
bpcl um and now you are a data analyst
by profession so how how did this happen
I mean why did you choose to upscale
yourself could you just think back on
the early the the starting point that
what what were the thoughts in your mind
uh and how did you go about it sure uh
so while I was working as a mechanical
engineer with
bpc I felt that that most of the
decisions that we used to take was EI
based on Intuition or maybe from
previous experiences or also uh I I
remember that we used to collect data
and then we used to enance the
performance as well that's how we used
to do the optimization now data as a
word wasn't there there at that time but
also I saw that this data science domain
is booming it was just starting at that
point of time and while I searched for
this I really felt that if I can bring
this all together in my tool belt it can
really help my help me grow because at
the end we were taking the decisions
through data itself so that's why I
really decided to go ahead for this data
science domain and start up Skilling
myself got it no that's that's amazing
and I I think that first step lot of
times for most people is the most
difficult one because there's always so
much inertia that you have a job you
have uh you know other stuff going on on
the family side and actually when you
thought about this you know taking the
first step giving it time investing
behind it I think that that really a lot
of times makes the difference for
everybody U could you tell us person um
how did you choose simply learn I I'm
sure that when you thought of uh picking
up skills in data you know there would
have been a lot of different
uh ideas and options so would love to
hear uh you know what what drove your
decision so I think uh there were
actually two reasons uh that made me go
for simply learn one was it was actually
in my budget so it was budget friendly
for me and then it had a real good well
structured course because I was actually
learning through various platforms like
YouTube blogs but at the end I wasn't
getting the picture what is actually
there in the data science like there are
lots of things and I was literally
confused and then when I went through
multiple platforms I saw that this this
is the platform where it is also not
digging me too deep on my pocket and
also giving me a well structured course
and I think altogether that decision has
been uh worth and I think in a few
months once I took this course I was
able to see the whole data science
domain picture in full I was a able to
correlate how I can actually use the
skills to even my uh if I go back to
bpcl I I was pretty sure that how I can
actually leverage these skills so
altogether it really helped me make a
mark in that industry and I I could see
that now I shouldn't have to just
restrict to being a mechanical
engineer well that's that's great to
know and uh feel very very proud of you
know being able to play a small part in
your journey I think that's what keeps
us going at simply learn that how can we
help people who are trying to make that
jump and make it little easier for them
by uh you know offering something that's
that's easy to understand gets you up to
speed um and so how did you uh you know
so what was the experience like I think
initially the structured course and the
program being uh affordable were things
that helped you make the choice but post
The Learning Journey could you also
share a little bit about what were your
key takeaways what are the top three
four things that you really uh enjoyed
in this program because obviously you've
you've done multiple programs with us
and and had a great journey right so
would be great to hear some of those
things I think uh the first thing that
comes to my mind is uh live
sessions as well as the instructors
because uh most of my instructors they
were coming from not just they were
instructors but they were actually
coming from some companies even one was
having its own startup and uh he was was
actually teaching us AI so it was really
interesting to see that what the real
use cases can be and how we have to
tackle that and also altogether the
comprehensive curriculum like one thing
was live classes but also we had this
self-paced videos as well so let's say
if I don't want to go ahead and I can't
do the live classes I can also start on
my own and also like uh coming to the
live classes part if I have to say uh I
cannot just go for one live class there
were actually parallel live classes
running so let's say if I can do a live
class this week in the morning I can
even go for other live classes at night
so we had that flexibility and I think
all together this whole curriculum if I
go back when I started and if I see now
so it really helped me build that
initial foundation and that was actually
necessary to let me know what all things
are there and now after I completed this
I was actually at the stage where I can
now learn and upgrade myself more
because resources are out there there is
immense knowledge but where to Target
and where to see I was able to do that
after doing this
course pres that is that is so good to
hear I think when we were catching up
offline also this was something that I
was sharing with you and you know for
the larger group that uh this was one of
the core uh reasons why simply learn
started basically as a leadership team
at simply learn we had this belief that
basically um in the world of data and
Tech in in the amount of impact that
technology is happening having on all
parts not just data and AI but also
whether it's Cloud cyber digital
marketing business all all around uh
people who want to upskill their biggest
challenge is the zero to one that
basically when you want to get into a
new domain understand a new skill set uh
once you are into the skill set then you
can learn on your own because you know
enough in fact lot of times we use this
word that once you have created that
Foundation then you know what you don't
know as well right and and then you know
how to find it out that you can
basically search online go to so many
resources and stuff like that uh but at
the same time that first zero to one is
where most people fill where they will
go to lot of uh videos YouTube has tons
of content on everything under the world
right and U we ourselves put up so much
of our content on YouTube it's it's all
free for people to go and learn from but
the challenge is more this that from all
of that free content and videos that are
out there people typically hit some
block that somewhere you don't
understand some concept or you're not
clear on something and if you don't have
somebody to help you immediately to
clarify that and kind of move forward
then you get stuck and and I think
that's what our entire Vision has been
that basically how do we make programs
that get you from zero to one and once
You' created that Foundation then you
should be able to learn on your own
right and and it was so good to hear
from you when we were catching up that
you you had that Journey that at the end
of the program you were able to reach a
level where now you are comfortable to
learn on your own and you've done so
many things since then by picking up
skills on your own and uh you know just
going to a different level so so really
good to hear that person um I think I
also wanted to share for the audience
that this point that you mentioned about
you know flexibility in classes that you
do one today you do one tomorrow
evening so so you were able to complete
a program that normally takes 6 to 9
months in two and a half months how did
that happen because normally that's
that's a big challenge anybody who's
working and doing these programs
together uh it it takes time right you
are struggling you're also doing other
things together but it was amazing to
see that your journey was two and a half
months and you were able to complete a
much longer program in a shorter period
of time uh so so what what worked for
you well uh I think uh I was going crazy
a it as well to learn all these things
that was uh the end Dent like I wanted
to learn all these things but altogether
I think I was able to manage all of this
because of my family as well uh they
were really helping me that time and uh
I was actually able to do multiple
courses simultaneously like uh since I
was working uh I I was actually doing if
I remember Python and r on weekdays at
night and I was doing big data and
Tableau on weekends in the morning so I
actually
took these sessions I selected the live
sessions in that order so that actually
I can complete four subjects at once so
I think that was the thing I I did so
that I could I could actually complete
it in
time so that's that's very commendable
and I think uh was really good to see it
almost seems like you got into your uh
engineering Journey mode that typically
when you have five courses running in
parallel and uh kind of pulling night
outs to get them done so so really good
to hear about
that so uh pran I'm I'm just thinking
that basically before we move forward
let me just check so I'm seeing quite a
few questions that have come in maybe
I'll take a couple of questions from the
audience and then we can continue
chatting about uh some of the other
areas um so I'm seeing a question from
uh dambar Chandra that basically you
know um currently he's working as a PHP
developer and wants to switch s to the
field of data science and data analysis
U and what would be the right way to
initiate the journey U
any person any thoughts that you wouldd
like to share that basically somebody
who a PHP developer sure like if you're
already a PHP developer you know more
coding than I I do so you know you
already have that under control and I
think data data science or being a data
analyst or data scientist uh it's all
about relating the whole data
perspective to the program there's a
programming part as well so I think for
you if you have to jump it will it might
get hard to learn or your own that is
also possible I won't say that is not
possible but just take a course like uh
that is what I always uh suggest anyone
take any course take a course and just
put your head down for 3 4 months or
five months and don't ask anything or
don't let
anyone go away from your trajectory like
people will ask you okay why are doing
this isn't is it worth taking it please
don't listen to those things like there
are so many noise just cancel everything
cancel every noise out there and just
learn just sit down there for five
months that I'll
suggest I think pres that's a great
point I mean this is something that
we've seen many times because you know
that there are
um thousands of people who enroll in
courses every month and uh everybody has
a different journey I think many times
one of the things that we've seen is
that at the end of uh a period let's say
when you look back after 3 four years
what lot of Learners tell us is more
this that lot of times before enrolling
for the course there is so much of doubt
and noise in their minds like basically
should I do this course or that course
or this course finally the Learners who
uh talk to us after many years is that
the critical thing was to take a course
it was not about because so in hindsight
nothing is perfect but it's more about
making a start that you basically pick
up a course you do it so let's say
whether you do data analyst or data
science or you do an AI course or a data
engineering course obviously you
understand and pick the best bet but you
you start somewhere that you basically
start somewhere and you move forward and
then that gives you more visibility and
you can change course saying that okay I
understood this now maybe I want to go
in a slightly different domain which
incidentally person I think that's one
of the things that's very uh interesting
about your journey that you took the
entire track almost that you took data
science as well as Ai and then after
that you have picked out a niche for
yourself could you also share a little
bit about that I I think this is just
question that's coming to mind related
to this that basically how did that help
you that you just took a larger uh
program and then after that it helped
you figure out what you wanted to do so
uh I think uh
whatever decision I took uh it was
something out of gut as well something
out of intuition but if I now see it's
something that is actually connected
everything is connected whatever I did
so after I took this whole course I had
a great amount of knowledge in lots of
subjects and actually I was thrilled but
nervous as well because uh if I if I
started looking at the roles they were
actually specific so if I if I need get
want to be a data scientist I need to
have good python skills R skills and
also a b maybe a bit of experience and
let's say I want to be a data analyst I
want to know at least Excel SQL Tableau
all these different different
categorizations I saw there in the
market so while I was doing this
analysis on my own I was also figuring
out what works for me best because I
used to do programming I was in love but
I think right now when I was doing this
course I actually figured out that I
don't love programming that much I don't
want to code that much intensively so
that was the point I decided that I I
shouldn't dive into the AI piece or to
the AI phase even though I know about it
so that's where I actually decided that
I should take on to the data
visualization route because it was
something that was really exciting me it
had that design part the dat part as
well as the analysis and that's where I
actually came to a decision that if I
have to Niche down because I can be a
generalist but I thought that if I like
something I will be investing more of my
time there so that's that's how it all
came together and I started investing
almost like uh 90% of my time to data
visualization and I think uh it has been
one of the best
decisions no that's that's great to hear
um and and I think uh you know as to
towards the end we'll again come back to
this I'm I'm also seeing a lot of
questions around this theme where
basically people are asking about
different walks of life that I'm a
programmer I'm a QA I'm a uh you know
I've done a degree in data and then how
should I shape my career so maybe I
think one theme that I'm clearly getting
is that towards the end maybe we'll
spend around 10 minutes just on this
that you know there are three four
different kinds of personas who are
trying to build a career in data and for
each person what would be the right kind
of starting point so I think uh we'll
hold on to a lot of those questions and
we we'll come back to that um but PR I I
wanted to move to the to one other
aspect that basically so how did the
course impact your career trajectory
that basically so you you shared about
this journey that you were uh doing your
job as a mechanical engineer and then uh
wanted to uh get into the field of data
you took a program understood a lot of
the skills uh after that how did it
impact what what happened could you
could you walk through about the
transition and the challenges and how
you were able to get uh some of the
breaks that that took your in a
different direction sure so uh I think
uh if I start from the point where I I
was learning and then I left bpcl and
then I was rigorously uh searching for a
job in the data science domain so I was
uh forther first I was looking for any
roles so that was actually not working
out and also I Niche down myself so now
I know that I knew actually that I have
to focus on some specific roles and I
need skills such as Tableau Excel SQL
these are the skills that are really
important to me so I was working on them
I was polishing all of these skills
after completing the course as well and
I was actually practicing as many
projects because I had done some
projects in my course but that is not it
that shouldn't be the end if somebody's
saying that I have completed all the
projects and it's not reaping me
benefits then I think it's being knife
right now in this time or the stage that
we are in so I actually pushed myself
further so that I can have a really good
portfolio of projects and I think uh
while I was doing this in a few months I
actually landed my first job offer as a
table developer at a startup based in
Bangalore and I think that was a really
happy moment and uh like uh if if all of
us remember that uh moment from three
idiots like uh when when the CEO he
asked me that how much would you take so
that was actually one of the thrilling
moments I still remember that and uh and
after that um well I landed my job but I
didn't stop at my personal end so I was
also doing the
projects again like apart from the work
I was taking out some time working on my
my portfolio and I think within 5 months
after landing that first job offer I had
a job offer from American Express as an
analyst and uh I think from there uh I
have been at MX for around 2.5 years and
I left recently so in 2.5 years I got
somewhere around two promotions three
raises altogether it was a really good
journey and I think one of the crucial
habits was uh trying to up myself and
learning continuously so that habit that
eventually started with a program that
has be has helped me overall and I think
I'll be learning like I always learn I
try and go on buy courses even if uh I
am good with my
Niche no that that's amazing to hear
person I think uh especially even even
the overall theme that you're talking
about that basically keeps killing
yourself kind of resonates with 3D that
it's more about make sure that you are
skilled the rest will follow right so I
think that that seems to be the
philosophy that's worked for you but but
great feedback for everybody who's on
the call right that basically the
portfolio that you build that makes a
big big difference to uh getting the
getting the break getting the transition
um it's it's about projects it's about
having done enough so that you are
basically able to talk about it you're
able to Showcase it and you you have
that inner confidence that you've
executed real stuff it's not just about
learning theory and I think large part
of it happens in the structured programs
that simply Lear has where you've got
labs and projects and lot of it but I
think as pran mentioned there's also
beyond that that basically you do maybe
you do five prog programs or five
projects in the program but then there's
so much more out there and you could do
more and get more confidence and get
ready for uh the dream job that you have
so so PR thanks for sharing that um so
uh every Learning Journey also has its
challenges right that basically not
everything goes as per plan could you
also touch on that that basically while
obviously overall it's worked out for
you but what were the places where you
were feeling like you'll give up or
where you were stuck somewhere or what
were the challenges that you faced and
how did you overcome them what helped so
I think uh through this overall uh
Learning Journey I think at the start
while doing the course uh since I was
doing at a rapid Pace time management
was typically tough because uh I had to
complete the live sessions I had to do
the assignments and then uh we had this
major capsom project as well so I think
uh that was one of the crucial challenge
that I had at the start and uh I think
but
altogether uh I didn't face that much of
a big block because uh most of the
queries even let's say if I'm in today's
class and I'm not able to ask those
questions so I have my next live session
I'll be I was always prepared and uh the
instructors like I'll really commend on
that because uh every question I asked
uh it was actually answered and uh even
in the forums uh if uh I had any
questions related to the projects you
know even after the live sessions were
ended U those were actually resolved so
that really helped me overcoming the
challenges while I was doing this
program got it that's that's great to
know and and could you share maybe few
specific things that the instructors
were able to help you with so that uh
you were able to move forward fast and
and achieve the goal that you had sure
so
uh I think uh I must say U I already
mentioned it but I think it's the
patience of uh my instructors like u
whosoever i met I remember the names as
well they are um so they all of them
almost all of them had this uh immense
patience like uh answering not just mine
because I remember one of these sessions
I had this big data program now U one of
the learner was actually not able to
speed up and but the instructor like uh
some people were saying that we should
leave them but uh they were actually not
doing that even it took maybe like 5 to
7 minutes to solve that particular
problem for that single person still
they were doing that so I think that
that was really great to see even if I
am able to do that but I don't know like
every person learn at its own pace so
right I think that was uh really good
and U I think apart from the live
classes uh the queries whatever I had
and that were actually
soled like they were not taking a big
window altoe they were actually solving
all the queries of not just me multiple
Learners in a batch at a good Pace like
uh if I'm working at night and I'm just
putting a question I'll get that answer
in a few minutes or so so I think uh
that was that is really
commendable God it sure thanks pres so
pres what are your so where do you go
from here I mean where you are right now
I think was very interesting to hear
about your entrepreneurial Journey but
so what are your career plans what are
you trying to do and and what's the
future for
you so uh I think uh once I started
learning and I was pushing myself uh I
think in the year uh a few years back I
also saw that it's not just me that uh
is going through this Learning Journey
and uh I got invested in mentorship
because I saw that also read about it
that even if I have let's say just one
person % of the learnings out there
still who is just starting at zero it is
1% more so with that objective in mind I
started mentorships uh it was uh totally
one to one free mentorships I started
with that and U I think that has become
my core Mission so recently I quit my
job and now I believe my future is
totally dedicated to mentoring people so
that the things I tried out the the way
I approached the problems even at work
or with my career trajectory that I
should be able to help others and uh
with this in mind I also started my
first own uh tblu mentorship program uh
that is already running uh we are
already down three weeks and I think I
wish to take care of all these values
and I want to go ahead and help more
Learners out there like U who are
starting who are even facing troubles to
start and then I can be a helping hand
so I think this this is the core
objective of my entrepreneur journey and
I'm very excited about it so pres that's
great to hear so you you have so so the
tblo mentorship program that you've
launched you you are calling it tblu
buddy is the company and uh great to
hear that your first program is uh has
started off and and wish you really all
the best it it feels really good that a
simply alumni is uh kind of building his
own business business in the space and
and very very excited to hear about it
so really good PR I'm kind of uh detour
uh so apart from the world of data and
your career so what what are your what
do you like I mean what are your hobbies
what do you like doing so uh data took
me to many places like uh with data as
well like um I lead some of the tablet
user groups so I travel a lot to do
events at face places also I uh because
thanks to like being in the data field
and with Tableau I also went to
different uh countries so traveling is
definitely something I like exploring
new places also a bit weird if somebody
would find I really like anime I don't
watch anything apart from learning I
just watch anime or you will find me uh
playing FIFA
sometime so and I think U apart from
this still like uh you'll find me saying
this as a very geeky person but uh I
also spend a good time uh still working
on passion projects related to data if I
want to build a good visualization out
of a data that is present on kagle or
anywhere or maybe I'll build my own data
set I'll do that so that is where my
hobbies and interests
lie got it no person this is this is
great and uh I'm I'm sure the entire
audience is enjoying hearing different
aspect of your journey and maybe for
each person there's a different part
that resonates I mean for for everyone I
I think uh you know before really diving
into lot of the questions that the
audience has uh shared with us uh just
maybe a o over overview in terms of you
know what is your advice to
professionals who are looking at a
future in data how what what are the top
things that you would want to call out
and then post that maybe we'll get into
specifics of what uh the audience wants
to hear more about and take take more of
the
questions I think uh I I'm I'm almost
repeating myself here but uh I'd say
that see uh like search never ends if I
have to be very true and honest search
never ends if you'll be searching for
that very best course Very Best
instructor it never ends so take a
course and just sit down and spend some
amount of time without question in even
the course or the learning or whatever
the structure is your only focus should
be on learning things it will help you
so much because uh I've seen many people
who take the courses and then they have
all these questions will I get a job
what will be the questions in an
interview I think that can be taken care
of but first you need to have those
skills right because uh in this industry
right now skills are really important if
you don't have skills nobody is going to
touch you or look at you so that is
important and this whole data science
domain it's a really big domain and it's
also expanding at a great speed so
knowing different Technologies let's say
you go for a data science or AI course
that is good to take if you have some
experience with programming or coding
because uh there will be intense
programming if you're especially going
for the AI course but uh doing a let's
say a holistic big course like data
science and AI course
really helps me right now because while
I was leading the data visualization
team at American Express I had to
actually collaborate with AI teams data
engineering teams product management
teams so this whole information was
actually helping me to actually
collaborate with them so I think that
where it helps me almost so that I can
actually understand what they're talking
about if they're talking about confusion
metrics if I'm just I don't know about
it I cannot make any sense but since I
had that information already it really
helped me but let's say if you're coming
from a very different background let's
say arts or Commerce or maybe from a
philosophical or psychological
background there can be anything I I've
seen people who are dentist they want to
become a data analyst like I've seen
such messages in my inbox as well so if
if you're coming from such a background
pick up those uh simple skills they are
still in demand and one of them is my
favorite that uh like my whole career
depends on it that is Tableau you can
invest your time with Tao Excel SQL I
think if you have good exposure and
skill with these skills then you can
actually get onto a data analyst role
and I think that is something you should
go for if you're coming from a
non-engineering or a non-mathematical or
non-programming background so that is
all I'll suggest today
got it no uh PR I think some really
really uh key points over there I think
I I definitely want to expand on one of
the things that you said that this this
entire piece about putting your head
down and learning um and a lot of times
there are distractions where people
focus more on the end outcome more
rather than the process right and I I
think see at the core of it one of the
things that we have always had at the
core for for simply programs is that
finally it's for your career go so
everything is designed for that but
there is a journey that basically and
and I think you captured it beautifully
that so for us our entire program design
also works that way saying that first
you have to absorb the skills nothing
can be done without the skills once you
get those skills after that you
basically learn how to apply them which
is where the portfolio comes in that you
are doing five seven 10 projects and
you're building a portfolio all that
goes on your CV and you have that that
I've done this stuff so I know it I can
answer questions on it and all of that
right so that's the second layer the
third layer becomes more this that if
you have the skills and you if you've
done the Hands-On work then how do you
actually showcase yourself and which is
where you sometimes also need
credibility that and that's the kind of
certification that simply learn gives
that you have a simply learn certificate
that's your foot in the door people will
get you an interview you'll get the
chance to talk about it talk about what
you've done and if you had this skills
and the portfolio then you will be able
to crack a job so lot of times there is
lot more focus on basically and I'm
incident seeing that in the questions as
well saying that how do I get a job how
do I get a job actually the path is very
simple and and that's what you've called
out saying that first get the skills
forget about everything else put your
head down just learn then build your
portfolio which again you touched on
saying that building the portfolio is a
very critical part and then we get you
the credentials as part of this program
if you complete the program you have the
credentials that will get you a foot in
the door last part is always up to the
learner that he has to pull it through
so I mean I think nobody can take credit
away from anybody that finally if person
like you are successful you successful
it's not like anybody else can do it for
you so I think thanks for you know
calling it out for the audience and
that's something that I would also want
to reiterate that it's always that first
put your head down and learn then build
your portfolio and we'll give you the
tools to do that then eventually you'll
be ready to get
you know get the outcomes that you want
and I think that that's something that
should help people a
lot I think the other thing that you
covered which was my next question which
you've already answered which is that
what program should people start from
depending on their background and that
again in brief that you know if you are
already a programmer then you could take
a more advanced course if you are a
complete like a dentist should start
with data analyst and visualization and
some of those skill sets which don't
require Advanced coding and stuff like
AI or data science uh I think that also
gives a lot of perspective to our
Learners I'm sure it answers lot of the
questions that we have as well which
many people have asked um so I I think
this is this is very very helpful person
I think thanks for sharing this
perspective why don't we jump into the
questions and let's see you know apart
from the stuff that we've been talking
about what do our audience want to know
about I I think uh we had gone through
one from a programming perspective that
if somebody is a programmer where should
the person start uh another question
that I see here is that is data science
good to know as a fresher uh pran you
want to maybe share thoughts on that I
think yes uh let's say uh by fresher if
you're meaning uh if you mean that you
don't have any experience then yes
because uh even if we don't accept it
uh everything around us is going about
data so like even let's say you don't
want to Target a role in the field of
data learning about data science will
help you
at every aspect because just think about
it because uh right now people are
always thinking that I do this course
data science course and I get a analyst
or let's say a developer job or maybe a
data scientist but if you're working
let's say as an HR and you have these
skills then you can still analyze those
information and even present it to your
seniors so this whole information helps
at every profession right
now yep no absolutely and I think data
has applications across the board
irrespective of which domain you get
into U you're always going to find it
very useful um prison uh one other
specific question I think people want to
know which courses have you done uh at
simply learn so maybe you want to call
out which are the programs that you've
taken so I took data science and AI
Master's course so both the courses I
took uh it was really intensive and um
especially the ai1 it had so much
mathematics I didn't knew that I had to
face again so much mathematics but those
are two courses I
did great thanks thanks for sharing
um some of these questions we've
answered I think uh you know which
course is best for me to enter data
field I think we've given some
perspective there uh I'm just running
through some of the other
questions so again Shivam is asking that
he's a final year student in masters of
Economics wants to figure out whether
data analyst or data scientist what's
the direction I think sh hopefully we've
we've addressed that in terms of how we
should think about it I I think this is
again a very interesting background and
person wanted to bring this up uh
because it might be relevant to many of
the people that typically the way we
think of segmenting is that there is
programming skill then there is
mathematics skill and then there is
somebody who comes from a very different
background and for each person what
would uh make sense right and I think at
least the so so what we've seen is that
um somebody who's coming from a non-math
non-programming kind of a background
then data analyst is the best place to
start because then otherwise if you get
into data scientist or AI then it
suddenly becomes too much outside of
comfort zone and then people struggle um
but starting with data analyst and
eventually you could move to data
scientist or AI um and then if somebody
has programming as a skill in general
maths is part and parcel of it because
somebody who's learned programming
probably has a background in maths as
well so directly going for data science
and AI works out um there are a lot of
people who have math skill but not
programming skill and there typically we
advise them to take a data science
program uh they could also take a data
analyst program but data science could
also work out because they have a strong
grounding in mats U any any other
thoughts on this you feel or or you
broadly this resonates with how what
what you've experienced as well I think
I think you covered most of like with
this specific uh question like Masters
in economics I think uh if if you H if
you know U if you have a good hold over
maths I think even you can go for the
data science course and alog together
what Kash mentioned it makes sense
because uh whenever you're starting just
also not take too much on your plate so
taking that decision is really crucial
So based on that you you should be
taking a
course I I think there's a very
interesting question and I wanted to
take that that there's somebody who's
asking that I my age is 40 and had an
experience that companies want younger
stuff in data science is it really so uh
I I think the way I would answer that is
that see I think practically for any
company they would look at uh creating a
skill set in any domain which has longer
uh you know period uh for growth that
basically if I if you can get somebody
who's younger and can grow and take on
more responsibility with time I think uh
that there would be some preference to
it but the key thing for somebody who
has more experience and wants to get
into data science it is more about how
do you play on your experience like for
example if there is somebody who's an HR
professional for a long time and that
person does an HR analytics program
right or or somebody is basically a
marketeer for a long time and takes up a
marketing analytics program which are
all components of the programs that we
have then you can basically play on that
that basically you are kind of doubling
down on the domain where you have
expertise and that's what creates unfair
Advantage for you right so I think
my suggestion to people with more
experience out there would be that you
need to get data skills if you want to
move in that direction but you'll have
to create a niche for yourself that
what's your experience plus data how
does it becoming how does it become
Larger than Life and that can help you
get growth opportunities but if if it's
just about basic data analyst skills and
you you are talking about entry-level
jobs most likely yes you are right that
companies would prefer uh somebody who's
probably younger but that that's where
you need to use your EXP experience in
the right
way I'm seeing other questions uh kind
of repeating now a little bit because
it's it's normally these so either
programmers or non-programmers or uh
people who who've got some experience
let me try and find if there's a
different set of questions that we can
touch
on um and uh RHA here if you want to
help just let me know if there are
questions that you're seeing repeating
and if you want us to take it I think uh
would be helpful as well but in the
meantime we'll go through all the
questions that are
there sure
sure yeah no I think uh it's seems like
uh those were the themes and I think we
have covered uh quite a few of them and
I I'll let Russia pick up if on the chat
window if there were questions that we
haven't covered which which are wor I'm
sharing one with you sure on the chat
here okay
uh so I think uh so uh pres there's a
question from uh
someone who's an mtech in corrosion
science and has been working in a
chemical plant Etc but wants to change
and Shi to data analysis or data science
U you know he doesn't have a background
in coding and programming so how should
he go about
it so I
think right now if uh you you are
already working so first like don't be
like me and leave your job that is the
first thing I'll suggest but yes pick up
the data skills and since you have a
good amount of experience try to apply
it at your work
itself whatever data skills you are
getting let's say how to do analysis how
to use Python how to solve
problems you need to apply all those
skills at your current organization or
your current workplace because I think
that's the best ground if you want to
have some projects because uh one of the
most dis biggest disadvantage can be
like if you're not working then you have
to do all the different projects but if
you already are working then I think uh
you have a good advantage that you can
use those skills and build a project at
your workplace as well and yes further
going ahead you can do more projects and
then if you really want to get an
analyst role or a data scientist role I
think you can go through that as
well
and and here I think uh you know one
opportunity that I want to take is to
kind of Club these uh questions in few
buckets right that basically I think you
know anybody who's um in the programming
domain ideally uh getting into data
science and AI is relatively easier
because you already have mats and
programming background you can take
these programs and definitely would be
able to go through it and master these
skills anybody who's in a
non-programming background and has let's
say five years experience or lower then
ideally data analyst is a good program
to start with it gets you into the field
of data you have exposure you can figure
out uh you know data analyst
opportunities data visualization
opportunities and so on um at the same
time if there is somebody in a non Tech
kind of a field and with more experience
let's say 8 10 years of experience and
wants to get into the field of data I I
think uh the suggestion would be more
this that you you should look at data
along with your functional expertise so
how do you create that combination that
you've got 10 years of functional
expertise in some domain you get data
science skill sets in that area and you
as as person also touched on grow within
that uh domain that basically over there
your thought process if you already 10
15 years of experience in a domain
ideally this data skill set should help
you grow more in that path rather than
trying to think that after that you will
basically start as a fresh analyst and
then go through through the entire data
analyst journey I think that would be a
challenge for you so hopefully these
three four different uh angles can help
everybody on this call try to think
about it that you know what's perhaps
relevant for them in terms of taking it
on um and once you are clear about uh
you know a specific Direction in a
program I think uh one of the biggest
takeaways I would reiterate from PR is
that keep your head down and first get
the skills right I think that's the
starting point and you need to get that
done before before you can think of uh
the the larger outcomes and what will
follow sometimes we focus on the goal
and we miss the process and that that
doesn't help in terms of uh getting to
the right
point so I I have a question here that
can we get a certificate for attending
this webinar uh unfortunately not I
think you should enroll for a course
immediately
right but uh but pran this has been
amazing I think uh thank thank you so
much for taking time out and sharing
your perspective sharing your journey um
it's it's been great having you here and
uh uh you know amazing interaction I
really enjoyed it and uh I'm sure our
audience enjoyed it as well um thanks to
the audience thanks for everyone to come
in over here I'll be handing over to
Russia now uh I think uh to share a
little more of perspective on some of
the programs that simply Lear has and uh
you know helping everybody on the call
that if you need help in figuring out
what's the right program for you you can
interact with our team so rasia over to
you and uh yep thanks once again PR
thank you thank you so much kab thank
you for having me uh thank you so much
kab and PR for sharing uh pres Journey
uh and uh yes I'll take you through the
most popular business analytics data
science and EM courses we have here uh
so we have a variety of programs in data
science data and LS and a learning and
we have Partnerships with top
universities in India and globally like
IAT CLE Caltech puru won and many more
like that uh we also have a Masters
program uh that cater to data rated
roles like data scientists data Antics
Nei engineer uh so as you can see I I
can basically show you few programs here
on the screen and also share you the
links in order to if you want to explore
more programs from here so I'm just
sharing those uh basically category
links here on the chart here in you want
to uh explore the program so we have a
professional certificate course in data
science by i k here we have professional
certificate course in dat Antics by idur
again uh and C postgraduate programming
data science uh and postgraduate program
data science by P University uh postu
programming data and FX by again like P
University and data and FX Masters
program uh this is in Partnerships with
our silver business partner IBM and few
more courses which we have which we are
covering uh in this particular webinar
here is professional certificate courses
courses in AI machine learning by it
compo calch postgraduate program in AI
machine learning by calch here and uh
postgraduate program in AI machine
learning by P University and by what
online we have ai for de decision making
business strategies and application and
uh again like master's program here for
artificial intelligence engineer uh here
we have a syllabus silver business
partner IBM and MSN artificial
intelligence by IU Germany so uh these
program come with the comprehensive and
Industry aligned learning path and you
get access to integrated Labs projects
for hands-on experience and uh you also
get access to online virtual classrooms
with live instructor interaction and in
case you are a working professional uh
this programs are flexible to fit your
uh schedule and you can just complete it
by giving 5 to 15 hours per week
depending on the duration of the program
so uh as we have mentioned earlier so
these are the programs which uh we cover
in um business analytics dat science and
AI machine learning so we would love to
know your interest which program are you
interested in R you can see four uh
programs here uh in this poll which you
see here so calics postgraduate
programing data science the second one
is master's program uh data analyst
master's program data scientist the
third one and the last one produce
postgraduate programming data science
so you can select from the options which
you see in the poll here uh we have
talked about basically what skills what
projects you know what it to basically
for even prent to you know complete his
program
here and also in case you have any
questions about the program in general
you can basically uh me mail us at askus
simple.net I'll be sharing that email ID
here uh in case you want to inquire
further about the programs so learning
Consultants from cly Lear will be
reaching out to you and taking you
through the program in much more detail
or any other program you know apart from
this you'll be you would want to explore
so I'm just sharing those details here
on chat here as well for you to
basically check out and also I'll just
share the program details category of
selection we have the most popular
curate programs for business analytics
uh data science in machine learning here
as well in case you want to check out
these programs in MA as I speaking uh
for have already started selecting which
programs they are interested in
enrolling so I'll just give like some 10
seconds more uh before we move on to the
Q&A part I think we have taken a lot of
questions throughout the session so I
think we might have very few questions
to answer but we'll just give like maybe
like few more minutes you know if you
folks have any more questions you can go
and put out in the Q&A box we'll take
those questions before we end the
session and uh meanwhile uh I'll just
give 10 seconds more for the poll here
so which program are you interested in
enrolling you can see like four vares of
program here some of which we have
covered through presence Journey here as
well also folks about the cohort of
these programs we take only 25 to 30
folks per cohort in order to make sure
you're getting all the attention you
know that is required while you be
taking up these programs here so uh so
also like we make sure that the Cs are
limited uh and uh basically we basically
you can check out the upcoming course
and the link which I've shared here I'll
just share it once again in case you
want to check out uh the programs here
once again so this is for the data
analytics and business uh data Sciences
business analytics field
here awesome I think I can see most of
the folks have already shared their
interest in enrollment but I still see
like uh few few PS moving in is still so
what I'll do is just give like five
seconds more before I close this poll up
and we'll move on to the Q&A part of the
session so 5 4 3 2 1 I'll just end the
poll awesome uh thank you so much for
sharing that with us uh as I said that
in case you have any questions you can
always reach out to us at ask USS
simple.net uh and basically let us know
what your queries are I'll just quickly
share that email ID here once again in
case you have missed that in the
previous message which I've shared here
and now we'll just move on to the Q&A
part of the session uh as as I mentioned
that we have taken a lot of questions uh
throughout the session so maybe let's
just browse through the questions we
have here if you have any new questions
Kash and pran uh and maybe let's take
those few questions let me just quickly
browse through if you have gotten any
new questions
here so I think uh RHA we uh did glance
through it and we've tried to cover many
of the questions I think maybe we can
take a couple of minutes and see if
there's a class of questions that we
missed uh maybe any of the attendees if
you feel that your question has still
not been answered could you just go
ahead and type it again and we'll see if
any any more questions come in then
we'll try to probably take those sure
sure folks uh please we've got a long
list here I mean we've got about 60 70
comments and we did go through it and
try to answer uh most of the common
questions but yeah I think maybe the
audience could just write it again if
they feel their question is still not
answered yeah we basically are done with
our webinar timing duration as well so I
think few more minutes folks let us know
if you have any questions you can let us
know in chat or in the Q&A box so we
just uh looking through the questions
here so I think kha we have answered I
think all of them so uh I think we'll be
moving towards the end of the session
here so uh once again like thank you so
much kashak for you know uh taking us
through this webinars Learners SP web
and Preston also thank you so much for
joining us and you know sharing your
journey here with us uh would you like
to say something kab press like before
we ENT the
session yeah I think pran you want to
address everyone what would you like to
leave as last
thoughts I think uh since we're talking
about learning and upscaling then uh
it's essential right now if I talk about
the market it's really essential and uh
just go ahead and start
nothing more you should do do about it
whatever you have let's say you want to
switch to any domain or you want to get
a job you want to get into research you
have to start with learning so that that
is my last words for the session here
thanks person and I think I would kind
of echo the thought uh you know I I just
want to leave leave the audience with a
couple of thoughts one is uh exactly
what presson said that uh you know the
biggest biggest problem is inertia lot
of times we keep thinking about this
problem and that problem and how to make
every Everything perfect but the biggest
challenge when you think about upscaling
or when you think about doing something
different uh in your journey in your
career is inertia because there will
always be five doubts to tell you to not
do anything so break inertia uh if you
are interested in a space go pick up a
program go learn a few skills it will
always be helpful whether you build a
full-fledged career in that area like
Ron has or or you basically use those
skills in your Walk of Life and it
really helps you in terms of doing what
you are doing better I think data
especially is a field that even if you
don't become a data expert if you don't
become a head of data science somewhere
even then data is something that will
transform the way you look at your
everyday work right so I think it's a
great skill to pick up if you are keen
and if you have taken out time to come
to this session and try to get your
questions answered I think my suggestion
would be more this that you are
motivated enough you should do something
uh pick up a program learn a few skills
uh I think it'll definitely go a long
way the second part is more this that
from uh you know simply learn side our
um vision is always to help Learners
like you to basically get to a stage
where they can build a career in the
area that they've picked up uh that's
what keeps us going so really thanks a
lot for taking time out and uh coming
for the session I think what you'll find
in most of our programs is going through
this journey that we spoke about in this
webinar that first first get the skills
then apply them build your portfolio
build a set of projects that you've done
so that you really confident and the
certifications that we'll um get you by
the end of your program if you complete
the program whether it's a simply learn
certificate or some of our great
Partners like ctech it perdu and so on U
they will set you up to get a foot in
the door the last mile of getting that
job getting that opportunity is finally
going to be up to you you have to master
the skills you have to do the projects
you have to be able to tell your story
right so so that's how I would want you
guys to think about it and wish all of
you all the best yep I I think that
that's probably what I'd like to close
on uh thank you so much folks uh so
we'll be ending the session now uh
please do reach out to us at ask us at
simply. if you have any questions about
the programs we have and also folks have
already shared their interest towards
enrollment to the program which we have
shared uh learning Consultants from
Simply reaching out to you pretty soon
so thank you so much so much once again
thank you we'll be ending the session
now have a good evening good morning
good afternoon wherever you're joining
us from so thank you folks thank
you thanks everyone thank you bye
everyone